So now that I've got the pen back,
we're going to wrap this up by talking
about something we promised to talk
about at the end of the last class,
which is Mechanism Design.
>> Cool.
>> Right, this seems reasonable right?
>> It's like mechanical engineering.
>> It is not like mechanical engineering
except in a very abstract and
analogy sense.
>> Okay.
>> So
what mechanism design is it's kind of
the art the science and engineering,
dare I say it, of creating games to
elicit certain kind of behavior.
So, so far what we've been talking
about with our solution concepts and
all the things we be doing in game
theory one, two, and three so far,
is we've talked about what
happens when we play games.
And at least stepping back a little
bit what we get when we play games is
we get certain predictable behaviors and
those behaviors are natural.
They're natural equilibria or
maybe they're correlated equilibria or
maybe they're cocoa whatever
you call equilibria and
other things we haven't talked about.
But here what we want to do in Mechanism
Design is we want to make a game so
just play a game but
again with the end goal of getting
some specific behaviors, okay?
Does it make sense?
>> It feels kind of like inverse
reinforcement learning in that we're
going from the behavior that we want
to a game that would make that behavior
whereas in regular game theory we
go from the game to the behavior.
>> Okay, I like that if I going to get
so much, I will draw the arrow that way.
So here, we have a behavior we want and
we're going to come up with a game that
would actually lead to that behavior.
I like that.
And then, once we've made a game, what
will happen is we'll get people to play
that game, and then that will
generate the right behavior.
>> Nice.
>> Okay cool, so
it's like a sort of cycle of life thing.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah it's not
a cycle though but sure.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> Yeah, but
I don't think that arrow means anything.
>> It means it's the identity function.
>> Lead to behaviors which
lead to a game, sure.
>> So there are lots of ways we could
talk about this but I think for
the purpose of this class, I think
the most interesting way to kind of get
across mechanisms design is
just to give a few examples.
So I'm going to give two, or
maybe three examples, and
sort of work through what is sort of
easy and hard about mechanism design.
I try to give you a feel for
why this is actually important and how,
by making little sort of specific
decisions you can have a huge impact on
the behavior that people have.
And in fact, you could argue that
everything that happens in politics,
the laws that we make,
they're all about mechanisms.
They're all about figuring out
how to influence behavior.
They're all about incentivizing
peculiar behavior.
So the big sample that people talk
about every four years when there's
a presidential election and
worry about, you know,
the budget is one of the biggest
sort of mechanism design things
implemented in the last several hundred
years, which is the mortgage deduction.
So, if you buy a house and you take on a
mortgage, you get a huge deduction, and
why is that a good thing?
Well because it makes
buying house cheaper,
is what actually encourages
you to buy a house.
And we think that's a good idea for
a bunch of reasons but
it doesn't even really matter
why we think it's a good idea.
We have actually constructed something
to encourage people to buy houses.
>> Okay.
>> So,
let's see if we can kind
of do this in the small and
kind of think about how you might go
about thinking about how you would
generate certain behavior in people.
>> Okay, sure.
>> Good.